because you're just psyching me out like
four hours ago i started preparing for
this
i've had why because that's what i i'm
gonna take the clips from myself like i
you really are aoc this is important
this sucks i'm gonna clip it and make it
a tick tock
five seconds of you just left okay all
right yeah
and so i started drinking uh different
caffeines
i worked out i took a shower like okay
well i didn't do it i wore a colorful
shirt for the podcast like wow wow then
you put a black jacket over it yeah
so that it could be less colorful just
limit to slim it all down
i'll try to keep it a fist away from you
so um well thanks for coming on our
podcast
thank you chris thank you for taking
this seriously you know
like some people around here what do you
you know you were cooking chicken before
this like what the
chicken before you only thought to get a
coffee after it started rolling
okay well that's beef that's after you
were just like berating me
for not being prepared somebody learned
a lesson um
yeah i learned a lesson i learned
there's nothing wrong with caffeine i
read it in a book recently
that like caffeine is only good like on
the thing as
long as it's only it's two cups if you
do more than two cups at a time
what about weed is the weed only good i
haven't gotten to that part of the book
yet and it's not
what book is this uh brain whatever
brain by nancy regan no
reagan so did you bring any like reagan
wouldn't be like
railing on coffee yes you would it's an
acceptable social dream
yeah look there's like scientists i've
been reading like scientific things
in the chapter on on caffeine and it's
like really good
i wrote a lot of stuff down hmm what
else do you
learn about it like people really did so
much
better like in all the studies and stuff
on like tests and everything after
caffeine and people who didn't have
caffeine did
so much worse on like memory seriously
drugs work
but it like we're saying caffeine does
what it's supposed to do cubs doesn't
work and also
um you should actually have it every
five hours throughout the day
but haven't heard tim ferriss say
there's no biological free lunch
i have heard him say that if you're
getting an advantage
from coffee it comes at a detriment what
is it
dehydration you have to [ __ ] later maybe
energy loss
where where's the energy loss in the
later parts of the day
you come crashing no i feel like you're
our father
right now because they they did the test
so
so it's like memory and stuff tests all
throughout the day
and like people on caffeine in the
beginning on caffeine all day
no caffeine ever like the whole placebo
thing and it showed that like the best
people did caffeine every five hours
and the people who did caffeine at the
beginning
didn't do worse later than the people
who never did caffeine then people who
never did caffeine did the worst
all day yeah who who texted you
nobody it's a notification it's a
productivity uh alert
what's your favorite contrast where
people are checking create a space for
good habits
it alerts me every two hours to my like
to tell you to do something
yeah um i have that it's called my mom
do you hear that
we got derek yeah he's gonna talk
just come in he's gonna talk no no he's
not
he can't we can just uh continue so like
what are you how are you doing today
hey look at this guy hello
um so what do you what do you what did
you want to talk about
um well i told you guys about the indian
the indian creature uh yeah so
you guys just kept saying indian racism
like
accent stuff how are you doing today
well that's what he was talking about
look at the alien
and um what else did i want to talk
about and
you guys just said that he is an alien
according to the us
it's a humanoid got two legs two arms
look there was a video
it was it was a blurry it was a blurry
guy walking around
and i've seen a thousand of those videos
and christy was like oh
oh this is so shocking like no one can
debunk this
no nobody has been debunking it it was
like yeah because nobody gives a [ __ ]
the only shocking thing was that it was
white and you can put on a white suit
yeah or you could be a white guy that
goes to india
what if riley was in india what if that
was me someone filmed it would he yeah
they would be like
they'd be like whoa alien [ __ ] ghost
demon creature so you're like offended
because you are
that white and everybody and everybody
all the descriptions like there's a lot
of american stuff on this
and a lot of the descriptions say it's
an eerie creepy
scary horrifying looking figure like
it's so funny because whoever comes out
and says that was actually just me
also the person's naked yeah it's a
naked woman oh
it's a woman so not an alien
dude what's wrong with you you think
that like aliens can't be humanoid
i think it's very unlikely that they're
gonna
a lot of people think that aliens are
kind of like a increased
like evolved future women so
why wouldn't they be here why wouldn't
they tell us about it would they be
planet-sized
why would they be in india
because they wanted to get some mango
they wanted to get some tiki masala
they don't have a sense of smell you
don't go there for all the like spices
um all of the spices yeah the curries
what about h-e-b yeah if i was an alien
i would hit up india every once in a
while to get the curries and stuff like
that
what the [ __ ] are you talking about they
might not even they might not even eat
they might not even have noses why would
you go to india also if she's a woman
yeah
they're not even on our planet if
they're alien they didn't we didn't
evolve from them
they didn't evolve from us so they'd be
completely different and uh yeah
i agree with hans but i mean also they
could be human
you know it could have happened the same
same thing
on a different planet as earth but just
like slightly different like
apes turned into grapes
and uh so apes turn into grapes no not
actually not actually a short circuit
apes uh apes turn oh i was just saying
i just like rhyming okay excuse me start
freestyling yeah okay i like rhyming
i'm just saying grapes yeah give me a
crack
because i'm about to rape i like
anything that rhymes with ape
yeah me too you want a vape yeah
like vape grape um
shape i like things that start with uh w
watermelon water women
weed white people white people do you
like women
they're okay they're not are you
bisexual whoa
that was dirty whoa that was all there
horses there
we don't want to reveal something
interesting on the podcast
yeah let's just try to keep this as
shallow as possible
yeah well like let's have people barely
get to know us
and then who uh those people
and then on the beginning of the bo
burnham thing he said what did i want to
talk about
content i was saying at the beginning of
the bo burnham
open your mouth little babies mommy's
got content for you well he also like
there's like a
video of the camera lens yeah remember
it's like zooming in on the camera lens
and like kind of making it seem like
this ominous thing that's like taking in
and you're like working like to like get
the lights perfect and everything from
this ominous like
black circle that's taking it in and
like
um what do you feel like i didn't catch
that that's very
perceptive it's very good and also like
it was tough for me because when i was
trying to get into tik tok like there's
you try to like i try to i'm always
thinking of new ideas because i want to
find a way where i actually enjoy it
yeah because like there's so many ideas
where i'm doing them and i'm like this
isn't fun
so i try harder where am i going to
actually enjoy it so i can do it for a
long time
yeah because if you enjoy it you're
going to do it for a long time so
follow your voice what yeah
so i can actually do it a lot yeah
that's why i do comedy because it's fun
and so do you like tic tocs or do you
hate there's just so many ones that like
it's too much work and
it's it's like i don't want to do more
this isn't
yeah well i find a lot of people just
copying each other and then
it's just like at a per at a certain
point it's just like
very unoriginal mine are original so
okay well i haven't seen yours okay it's
very uh i mean a lot of tick tocks are
just like low
effort it's like oh what's the least
amount of effort i can do like splice
together someone like jumping off and
dying and then your reaction to it yeah
well dude
i mean the [ __ ] the reaction thing is
so stupid like
it's a lot of just like posting someone
else's content and then being like
that was crazy so there is i actually
wanted to
do a whole tip like that there is one
stand-up comedian in california
who he's like has five million followers
on tick tock now and all he ever did
was do the splice thing and he actually
wrote comedy
for the thing so he like talked he like
actually talks in
okay yeah i mean if you're i mean
there's a way of doing it where it's
like
it's making it better yeah he wrote
he wrote and like figured out you know
30 seconds
of comedy for like as a reaction to
something
and it was so amazing and i like
followed him
to try that too freddie goldstein
no he does get dick talks he's a
comedian
okay i'll look at it but like whenever i
don't enjoy it it's always so
interesting because it's just like me
with this like camera
that i'm like staring into and i'm like
realizing that i don't enjoy this idea
yeah and what i'm looking at is like
just a [ __ ]
i'm in a room with a camera it's crazy
because you're alone but
you're alone but when you release it but
online everyone loves you
and in real life that's not what i was
gonna say that was a close guess
yeah because it's like a juxtaposition
between being completely alone
and related and also to the world yeah
like when you say when you say that
first high that's like the worst
thing about tick tock for me is like the
introduction hey guys like the first
hello
yeah the first section because you're
going from zero people to
like saying hi to millions and like it's
so weird to like
uh to potentially millions i don't know
if like i have to add potentially
in between that yeah um
so what so it's it's hard for me to be
like
i'm like sleepy almost i haven't spoken
to anyone and then i'm like
hey so is it like draining energy-wise
hello that's so draining why do you have
to do the hello like
you don't actually have to it's just
like if you
if you give a lot of videos that went
viral for me
and they were very out of context the
thing is that all the comments that come
through
are so angrily confused about
what is the context and they like build
a whole like narrative they're like
you must be you must be raping this guy
like you must be drugging this person
what are your content what does your
content involve they just like if you
don't
you always feel like you need to give
people the whole
story or else they're gonna like hate so
you're telling a story
in mass well i don't think you should
curtail your content for
the angry twitter mob yeah i know it's
just because like
you're supposed to if you engage with
the comments your algorithm goes up
yeah so you engage with the comments to
boost the video
but then the comments are all so toxic
yeah and uh you start to like listen to
them like oh maybe this is
true that yeah don't listen to them
they're a bunch of
hounds just barking interesting to get
like a yes or no like a binary was this
good was this not and then other than
that
just keep making the stuff that i would
make anyways without them
because if it's not fun for me i
wouldn't do it long term so if it's fun
for me
yeah that's what i'm trying that's why
i'm always coming up with new ideas
because like
i know that at some point an idea is
going to click that's like okay we can
actually
you have to like feel which one can go
for a long time
yeah that was loud but it's like uh what
you enjoy doing and like it's a weird
balance between what you like and what
you think people
like and what people actually like
because those three things are not
always yeah like this
it's like what do people like this
maybe if you committed more like have
you when's the last time you yelled
um in my car the other day
i yell a lot yeah i get really angry in
my car
and road rage road rage and then i start
crying and then blonde girl he was
crying rage against me she was like this
and beeping like
she was like this and it's like a young
blonde girl nice does she know what she
looks like
stay doing what i'm doing like i ruin it
even more when they
because then they get more mad because
well i just want to show them
it's like a roasting thing you just want
to show them like
this is what happens when you lose your
cool
is like i'm a prankster oh you're a
jester
you're a joker yeah dude that's what
happened to hans
i stayed in her lane a lot longer at a
slow speed as she was just like
and i was like i was looking in the
mirror and i was like this
it doesn't work it's like a child in a
temper tantrum your mommy will talk to
you when you're calm now
yeah oh yeah i [ __ ] hated that but
that's only going to make me less calm
exactly
but what was it which is why she did it
to a stranger one girl
it's weird to like for as a woman to see
like a stranger
like a young blonde can you see like
women are crazy
like the people behind you in your
mirror yeah dude because like that
people will probably see me just
just they'll probably see me and be like
it's like i need to check all the cops
like that guy looks insane
like i'll just be yelling and crying
and don't do that why not it's my god
work out work out my anger yeah yeah
definitely
dude i found out why i am so skinny is
because
i have anxiety and my heart is
constantly racing so i'm constantly
doing cardio
do you think that makes sense yeah that
could be yeah that's why you're not fat
yeah go to the gym do you no not really
so you wouldn't be
buff no i know but that's why i'm so
skinny always
it's cause like i can eat whatever i
want but i'm just like [ __ ] lucky
yeah because your brain is not
lucky i'm constantly in well
people like me would say that it's lucky
because
you're so fat i have a slow metabolism
okay well
i mean you have anxiety huh do you have
anxiety
no yeah well then you don't [ __ ] you
don't know what it's like
you live in a man relax but no i mean
i'm not gonna
get mad about that but like it does suck
i mean i'd rather
i'd rather have um i don't know what i'd
rather have
i guess i mean everything's a trade-off
but like you don't do it you're not
doing it
what are you doing to fix your anxiety
um comedy
i don't do yoga and i feel fine
well that's good yeah well
you sleep on the floor so you're doing
yoga when you sleep
as opposed to being slightly raised up
that's somehow
for a while you didn't i did i when i
first came into your
van and you didn't have a bed and you
just slept on a wooden board
yeah that's so asian i know for you
i was like i was like are you like yeah
i sleep in a bad
situation like it's really uncomfortable
and i'm just like
yeah so does your do you fit like
like lengthwise you have to curl up yeah
and like lift you
put your legs that sounds do you ever
open the car door
and then just let your hands up like
that because i'm not a i don't look like
a 400-pound bagel
so i can't i can't be open to everybody
at night
well i mean if you were a 400-pound
bagel you would be open
for sure
um well i mean that sucks that sounds so
uncomfortable and it's fine
so it's okay it's clean it's cleaner
than everybody else's bed
yeah i mean you don't need a completely
flat surface to sleep on
you just need relatively do you ever
like while you're ubering a platform
that you want to sleep on like uh be
like uh
i uh accidentally pee the bed last night
or you're like oh dude i've been peeing
on like
p has been spilling on it every single
day for like
spilling 10 days at least in a row
there's just been these containers that
i've been having for the past 10 days
that
spill it all over the like seats and
stuff yeah keep cleaning it and like
making oh no what do you use to clean it
up
various like cleaning supplies and then
um and then people get in the people
and they think it's a they're like is
this a bathroom yeah
it's a movie is this a mobile bathroom
dude that's a good
idea for drunk people man an uber
bathroom
like they'll just be i mean i guess
that's already a thing yeah porta potty
on wheels so you can puke you can pee
you can poop pee when do you guys think
uber will stop being a startup
is it a starbucks maintain when they
gain
market monopoly let's not do the
business thing
okay they did well they have lifts there
dude there's no more taxis like nobody
said people say
uber it's like kleenex people say uber
instead of
a car but it's not a good business model
they're like oh i bought a new uber
today
right uh
that's right i mean uh well i mean i was
just going off what you said
okay all right uh well
let's get to your political agenda what
are you going to do
for the homeless in austin
i was thinking the next thing i would do
every sunday i'm going to give
50 out of my pocket to them in some way
so like i was thinking
a great tick tock would be handing them
all umbrellas in the rain
don't give them umbrellas that's going
to be destroyed in a week
in a week that's going to be trash i'm
going to say
i'm saying that they're lit they're
living on the streets
i think an umbrella would be nice if i
was homeless
i'm giving it i'm not going they have
their do you have time
everybody's useful without an umbrella
when it rains i give an umbrella too
but umbrellas are so flimsy and very
easily destroyed
and another thing wet wipes
wow so they can wipe them they can
not get wet from the rain but they can
get wet from a wipe yeah just this isn't
about the rain anymore give them
the water towel they can just show two
birds with one stone
what do you mean because then they can
use a paper towel as an umbrella
and then after they're done it'll be
yeah the wet wipes the rain it's about
like
it's about keeping clean anal
cleanliness
but that'll make them acceptable to you
they don't give a [ __ ] how dirty they
are they want
something else but i have a different
perspective on
what we would do to help the homeless
yeah you would just
let them be beasts and just do whatever
it's not my fault i want to help them
make it easier to work and get
themselves
like i'm somebody who's been homeless
for two years and there's been times
like i had to sleep at a gas station for
two days because i ran out of all money
and i wouldn't ask for money i'm sure i
could have gotten gas money from people
but i slept where where in it in the
middle of
uh and um how was it
wow how was it it was terrible i was
really sad
was it there was no city anywhere figure
out the homeless problem
uh i know for two years i've been like
in these situations where
i suddenly kind of need some help in
order to like stay productive
to stay productive and so i want to help
people that are working
on beyond like i don't want to help
people that are just sitting around
like so what's the plan for them they
just they don't
they don't want to save themselves so
[ __ ] it they're just dead well
you have to help some people in your
life
you can't just be like wait i don't want
to help all of them so i suck no
you choose the people that you want to
help so if you want to help the beasts
then you can help the beast and i'm
going to help my
beast i'm going to help you so you want
to create like an olympics like a
homeless olympics and if you
get like above a certain mark then you
deserve humanity
if it looks like you're trying to work
so that's why i would give them
what are the criteria for for for your
group
trying just looking like you're trying
to work you're like
you're saying you're trying to get up
off of the like
cement i broke up on the wrong side of
the cement today
like i read i read a bunch of like uh
writings
by homeless people talking to the public
and a lot of them were really well
written like yeah obviously they write
very well
they use the word thus they punctuate us
that's homeless thus i am homeless tis
a fortnight ye
yeah and but but some of them were
really bitter
they would say like if you want to help
us
don't like uh don't tell us what to do
with the help
or if we want to use your money to buy
cigarettes and alcohol
yeah we deserve that we deserve a break
yeah like
and very like i understand where they're
coming from but that's not what i want
to help with
like yeah because you're very uh
yeah toy and then there's some that are
like
i just need this to like put myself a
little bit
but why are they homeless you're not
addressing the issue you're just judging
people for how they are suffering under
the system this is the reason why
they're homeless is because the system
is unfair
yeah in order to get into a starbucks to
like
be able to plug in your laptop and work
and everything you have to
not look homeless you have to not look
like a
hygiene problem so you have to a lot of
the women say they cut their hair
short to like keep it you should give uh
haircuts to homeless
fingernail yeah they they asked for
haircuts fingers literally
just wet wipes trimming away the edges
of the product yeah actually you know
what that means
so that they can get into it that's a
good point
it's just like yeah maybe they have food
maybe they have tarps
uh but they don't have cleanliness
products they don't have a society that
can implement like when as long as you
just
judge society you're kind of like
waiting for like
to vote again you know make a systemic
change
i understand and i'll vote with you but
like in the meantime
i'm going to be giving wet wipes to the
people with wet wipes too
right there you go yeah you need it
every single day every single morning
i wake up so disgusting it's your
natural human body every day i need to
take a shower every day
your skin produces maybe you should just
build like outdoor showers
for the homeless i can't do that because
i'm not an engineer i don't have money
i have enough money to buy wet wipes for
certain so like the black panthers
they the black panthers had like a
breakfast program and their whole
ethos was it's not your fault for
society's fault
and so when you take the blame out of
them then
they can just freely go get breakfast
and it doesn't feel stigmatized and it's
like a much better way to
help people instead of being like you
got to be clean you got to love jesus
you got to be
good you got to be tough yeah it's not
just
the system is the problem the bitter
homeless woman that you would love to
read her thing
was uh she would say like a lot of the
times that we have to take chari
that we take charity we have to also oh
thank you
thank you we have to also take [ __ ] from
whoever's giving the charity
right which is obvious
yeah which is obvious but it's like
yeah like the churches or whatever
they're like well you need to accept
jesus or something
in order to keep taking this charity and
then you're like okay i accept jesus
it's almost like the sock puppet part of
bo burnham's
yeah thing that was pretty crazy help
don't do it yeah that was crazy that's
the system i think that was illustrating
how a coercive
the system feels and how it like they're
threatening our existence reminded me of
the chinese thing i don't know if
everybody else thought that like you
need to be
like i want to keep existing well you
can't say that then
chinese the nba chinese china's
silencing people reminded me of america
chinese uh yeah they gotta keep working
they like silencers
they like uh silence well the way like
the nba players there's a billion of
them can you imagine if they were all
talking
yeah exactly that yeah exactly well i
can't even understand it
i think it's um i think chinese is a
beautiful language actually
do you have a wee chat you don't because
you're not even part of the chinese at
all
yeah i'm part of the korea like chinese
when they talk slow
is so it's it's like it's kind of cool
like it's pretty easy
i understand that you [ __ ] the chinese
girl and that's cool but like
i have never you actually say that
no she wasn't chinese okay so who was
talking slow in chinese
was it porn no just like in movies
uh like yeah like have you seen kung fu
hustle
no that's a good thing so you thought
that was beautiful when they were
talking
yeah yeah i was like um that's good i
haven't seen it
sorry yeah chinese is beautiful talking
about barnum uh silence homeless people
um what are you backing up yeah
because this is it's getting racist
what do you think about the future of
america do we have a future is it gonna
be china
uh the future is female
chinese female
future is uh well i really listen there
was a guy who wrote a book
on saying uh called a billion americans
oh yeah i heard about that
the first time i listened to that i was
in such disagreement the whole time i
feel like you
are in agreement with that we need a
billion americans because you like
people you don't think that there's
overcrowding
i think we can handle a billion i don't
know if that should be our main goal in
life
i think there's other things that we
should focus on it's because
when we realize that china is gonna win
it's because it's a lot
of because they have so many people and
so if we like
make more than them it's like maybe
yeah stem cell yeah we have less than
them now and we beat them in the opium
wars
and stuff that was a long time ago
though it's getting a little bit it's
like technology that was before they
they didn't own we can replace 700
chinese people with an
app we don't need numbers we can just
have like a forklift
what happens to them do you care about
them who the chinese
yeah yeah i want them to have freedom
and join the modern world
but i understand why they don't because
america is so corrupt
they're they're in capitalism they're
they're the ones that are holding
capitalism up almost
i know but like the culture and the arts
and the music like they're
mute their movies suck now really do
that what about
your site what was that really korean
korean yeah
dude i've seen some really good chinese
films like what
um uh
i can't remember the names but i took a
foreign film class and i saw that
chinese films like their indie movies
are good but like their blockbusters
suck i guess our blockbuster
jackie chan jackie chan the one man
chinese that's a chinese machine yeah
he's probably the thickest chinese guy
in existence my favorite
chinese person uh moved to taiwan
so he's no longer part of the chinese
like
he's now taiwanese yeah is that owned by
china that's like a huge like political
problem it's like it's like uh
and at the united nations you're not
allowed to say the word taiwan
didn't john cena get in trouble recently
yeah i said the word tibet one time
and i was punished for three months how
did it punish you i'd
work two hours extra every single day
that's crazy at the u.n
yeah that's just so cool you said it's
like a school
it's like a chill child i i said i love
tibet
and then china the chinese supposed to
be adults
there was a chinese guy you worked for
the chinese there was a chinese guy to
my left i didn't
i didn't know i didn't know that was my
first time realizing that people really
cared
that people were asian yeah the chinese
people were like that
they're pretty uh up front about why do
you interrupt like that
whoa what are you talking about i was in
the middle of a sentence
all right jesus oh my god sorry that's
crazy it's like you don't think i have
anything interesting to say
ever what i didn't know if you did i
mean sometimes
sometimes i prefer people to interrupt
me because the end of my sentence isn't
that interesting
yeah yeah yeah so you just interrupt
people but i didn't even think about it
i mean what are you you're acting like
china right now
yeah yeah demanding like i just realized
that brought us into this like weird
topic like right when you guys said that
i realized that i brought you into a
weird time
chinese people are usually uh pretty
apparently chinese
so maybe if you just turned your head
and looked for a second you'd have been
like oh
china china problem i didn't know that
they
were so mean i had no idea i thought
everybody was like chilling
chilling everybody all billion people
were chilling sorry i interrupted him
at the united nations like there's this
people do whatsapp groups
and basically there's a whatsapp group
for everyone who's social
to like hang out with each other and
it's literally every single year
yeah it's every single country syria is
social that's pretty cool north korea
invites us to lunches free lunches
in north korea so communism at the
united nations
so is it just like how many people are
representing each country
192. i don't know it's like it's
different for each one like france has
more than all of africa dude so which
country like parties the most
australia drinks all day that's pretty
chill
um so okay what are some other like
the chinese do not participate
yeah with the whatsapp group even the
chinese that are literally like you walk
to lunch with them like
that and you're like well they don't
have like facebook in china
they have what's happening like you're
like please let me invite you onto this
whatsapp
group so we can all hang out and they
say no like they're on a they have their
own chinese whatsapp group
yeah and that they're the only country
that does that
because they're focused on winning
they're kind of at their [ __ ]
why would they not be out it was really
scary um
i mean so what are some other like
countries that are like
chill like what are what are
some other countries that like what
what's their thing like
like australia's party like what are
some other well australians drink beer
all day i don't know if they party
necessarily i mean i would assume they
partied
their drinking beer i don't know like do
you guys have any
koreans i don't remember meeting any
koreans
they're traditionally kids you probably
thought they were chinese love to
have their mouths open a lot that's like
i heard that i love that i could be
korean
like in japanese people keep their
mouths closed as a politeness saying
like a type and then koreans are like
that because it's like sexual and
playful
yeah and why they cover their mouths
when they laugh
or when they even more childlike it's
like an extra low home
it's because like the mouth is such a
big signal it's like ah look at me
wow we've got teeth it's like yeah it's
trying i mean animals do that when they
when they try to insert their dominance
like snarl
yeah try to make their face bigger i
guess so
but japanese people it's like about
being polite and classy and tough
that they like even i know yeah japanese
uh they're really strict on themselves
that's why there's commit suicide so
it's kind of japanese yeah
except i used to hate japanese people
because i wrote an essay on
their war crimes they're crazy their
military just took over the
country and they're like trump they're
like we're gonna attack everything
all at the same time and they lost world
war two because they were stupid
militarily
yeah they had cool headbands though
didn't they rape you guys
the rape of nanjing was [ __ ] japan on
korea china
[ __ ] but they have comfort women
yeah they did they would take our
hottest women
take them to japan and then their
soldiers would come home from war and
then they'd just rape him all night
yeah i had to read about all that and i
was like i [ __ ] hate japan
yeah it's a warrior they're nasty they
uh
prize power and violence and their food
is so boring
their food is so boring really japanese
steakhouses
ramen i haven't been in one of those
ramen's pretty
is ramen japanese yeah i thought it was
chinese if
if if i could choose to go to any asian
restaurant
and they were like all there i would
choose a japanese one what
tonkatsu yeah i would choose which one
would you choose vietnamese if it was
like literally all in a row yeah
like thai chinese korean chinese
thai korean ties which one would you
choose if they were all the best ones in
a row
yeah tai would be my second choice or
chinese
but like chinese do have a lot of weird
food like pig anus and stuff
chinese american food is completely
different from chinese food i know
i know and but that's the case with like
everything like tiki masala is not a
thing in india
well i wonder what it means well it's
like it was created by like
british chinese uh indian people and
then because british people love it like
that's like their national food
of england let's take masala and they
can't get enough of that [ __ ] british
people are crazy
aren't you are you british or irish
irish
i mean yeah i mean british people are
nuts oh it might
oh it's just like it's crazy but like
they're
like i respect them you know why because
i respect everyone equally
just a human respect they killed 100
million indians due to famine
why did they eat them no they just
didn't plan they just sold all the great
they usually
have reserves but then they sold it all
to make more money
and then they're like oh well that sucks
and it happened year after year after
year and a hundred million indians died
should we be funny yeah well i've been
trying to
but then you guys you guys want to be so
serious and oh yeah and they're like
yell at me
you just let riley talk the whole time
yeah you said something and then i
got went off would you just have a
podcast it was you
it was me all along wait so really fast
british people are so ugly that in south
africa
there's two different white people
there's dutch and british
and you can tell based on like
one is ugly and the other one is hot
dutch people are dutch people are hot
yeah
yeah they are yeah you're like oh you
must be british dude you look like a
toad
yeah oh chav chav mate i'm a chav
chick i'm british that's what they say
all the time
oh british what's a chub chav
it's like you know those like girls in
britain with all that face makeup and
like
a big eyeliners but like oh oh he
[ __ ] knocker
uh he [ __ ] oh you don't [ __ ] with us
might and it's just like those annoying
ass chicks like it's maybe
it's basically like the little baby of
england what
cashmere
little baby yeah yeah i almost like
sometimes get near that near bad baby
no like i'll get long nails and i'm
about to get i don't know
i mean yeah you're you're and then i get
mad up to the line you know
so i'm like like that hey what the [ __ ]
crazy to be a one of those i'll do lip
liner
like wow and then you just go
around like pushing [ __ ] starting
crying move into different styles as
easily like you can't just suddenly be
why are you criticizing us
yeah what like what do you think i
should criticize you
and how you talk i'm not saying goddamn
this is the problem
let her say what she's gonna say it's
like if you became a punk person it
would take a lot of
extra work like you'd have to go get
earrings
you know so you think we should be
chameleons oh
wait why can't we why we can't change
styles
just like men or whatever i guess it
takes a little bit more to because we
have personalities
well yeah you guys have more stuff you
can like put on and take off raising his
hand now
i think what chris is explaining is that
it's more we can't have people
off camera talking rapidly
it's more acceptable for women to change
their style more rapidly
than for men
you're wearing hats we have
personalities and you're just trying to
become whatever society likes so that
you can not be killed by
men i mean i would like to be able to
um be stylish i don't start wearing hats
for example yeah uh i should i want some
of those you know
those boots that are not really boots
they're like dress boots
and you know just like [ __ ] like that
but i don't
i don't feel like doing that because
it's just i get embarrassed by it i'm
like i don't want i don't i don't want
to be that guy it's just like oh i gotta
look fancy you have to be able to own it
when you do like
risky like fashion things you have
people are like people roast you at
first they're like what the [ __ ] and
then you have to be like yeah i like
this thing
yeah i mean i guess i don't really care
it's just like i see someone else
wearing i'm like that looks good
but like i don't want to like go out of
my way to look like
you do have to go buy it and [ __ ] yeah
and just like what
[ __ ] what you're just going to like yeah
girls are the worst
girls have like uh dresses and they're
all different at the oscars
girls yeah men have tuxes and suits
they're all the same
yeah yeah because we're not that type of
person that changes our
dress doing that we're not wearing
colors what would you guys wear
like if you went to the oscars or
something like that would you guys just
wear a suit yeah yeah really you
wouldn't try to wear something funny or
like different
no if i was invited to the oscars
i would want to make sure that i
don't get kicked out you sound scared of
them
you're gonna like bow like make sure
that you don't i mean
but i mean it's also just like i don't
want to
i don't i don't want to do that like wow
yeah like i mean the
like trey parker and them did that at
the oscars that was funny
or they dress like women the south park
people yeah yeah
um that was gross though because they
like it's ugly
yeah you know and they their own acid
like it's like i couldn't think of like
whoa
what what are some things that i could
wear that would be funny i don't know
just like fun
like if i was a man i'd probably go to
the thrift store and just kind of look
around for fun things
the thrift store like a good look
there's people making like
35 million a year i like thrift stores
because it's like an adventure like you
don't know what you're gonna see
you know if you go to other stores you
know what you're gonna see so it's like
not fun
yeah i like that i like thrift stores
too like um
yeah my favorite shirt right now i have
i got from the thrift store
yeah is that did you get that from no
this one
i got this from goodwill yesterday wow
that's so
good did you cut it or no it was like
this
goodwill is kind of [ __ ] though
because they make
people poor people pay for clothes that
i gave you dude they're raising the
prices a lot
yeah they've been raising the prices so
much this year it's like dude like
or is that really that good world of you
if you get free
[ __ ] from me yeah so you don't even have
to spend money on buying the product
yeah you have to pay rent well okay
yeah no they're [ __ ] up and also uh
if you stand where the donations are you
can just like take the donut
just go could i just have that and
they'll be hilarious
you know that's so underhand i bet
they'd kick you out
if you did that but i googled like what
is what happens if you
get caught shoplifting from goodwill and
you go to jail
like they're actually it's like homeless
jail wait if you commit a crime you go
to jail
no on google it says there's like a
homeless guy who literally stole like a
shirt from goodwill
and they still like they called the
police they did the whole thing even
though
there's a lot of thievery from goodwill
that you should just kind of let slide
like if a homeless guy comes in and gets
a shirt yeah it's a free shirt well
people are next already
that sucks it's like you should have
some good will
yeah hello
derek have we been funny i'm on caffeine
y'all
y'all need to be funny and then i'll
join okay let's switch it
in the leading position
all right now that it's true
yes thank god the woman is silent the
way that men get to speak
the men get to dictate where the world
goes
um so i uh
been crying a lot why do you think that
is
because you're living in a capitalist
hellhole
i mean like but like uh is there some
things that you don't
that you blame like you don't blame on
capitalism like or just blame everything
on capitalism
i don't blame uh the
actually i blame i was going to say the
weather but then that's pretty
influenced by capitalism is it just like
you need
like if your brand is going to be
blaming capitalism then you're going to
need to do this
constantly for everything for 10 years
and well maybe just five more years why
does that have to be your thing now
but like it's just how i see the world i
know but it's like
you're you're like i don't know just
like it's kind of like
you're just like complaining a lot and a
lot of it is like uh
yeah not more short term not just
delusionally being happy like oh
everything's fine
well that's better than just complaining
and not doing anything
about it it's better for you because
you're the world's fine
for you but there's a lot that's fun
dude hans where do you get
all of your money where do you guys
never
you never work and you have plenty of
money
yeah you're like living in a van but you
just living in communism
well you know where he gets his money
capitalism
no i don't i get it from communism oh
it's part of capitalism though no it's
part of communism
that's why isn't taxes a capitalist
thing
isn't not a capitalist no it's a
socialist thing that's like capitalists
hate
taxes that's why libertarians are like
there should be no taxes
because they're taxis they're like we
got victory we're like on the top of
society now let's everyone just stay
here
nothing changed well it's kind of
irrational for you to say libertarians
don't want any taxes because like they
do
want you know to pay for like school
and like different things they just
don't want all the [ __ ]
the extra [ __ ] democracy who are you
guys voting for
you see the mayor the mayor of austin
said
there's only 240 people who keep going
to the hot
homeless people who keep going to the
hospital all the time and going to jail
it's just 240 people here
and they're costing each two hundred
thousand dollars a year or something
like that
i guess it was a year right each of them
so 240 times 200 000 a year and it's
just those
little group of people that's what
libertarians don't like it's costing
taxpayers
it's just this little group of like
nerdy wells literally
but they would exist because we have a
homeless population of 500 000 or
whatever
so a small portion of them are going to
be sick and need police intervention and
stuff
like they're the tip of the iceberg but
we don't like them
it's like 240 people it's like a small
massacre in iraq
but that's you rock club they exist
because we [ __ ] up
yeah i think they seem to be [ __ ] up
a lot right because there's
so much police we deserve it we deserve
to take care of them because we [ __ ]
up
with so many two hundred thousand
dollars in my whole life i've never been
able to spend two hundred thousand
dollars and
and somehow we have to do that
constantly for these people
yeah we need to take care of people and
it'd be easier to take care of them at
the front end instead of taking care of
them at the
back end if you guys need help but since
we don't take care of people
we have to pay 200 000. so this is the
price we have to pay
why is it why because we didn't give
them proper education health care
homes and so now it's not up to us to
take care of a lot
every single year they're they're living
like really rich people
no they're not spending 200 000 a year
70 000
and more is like a rich person but
that's not
that's a hospital cost that's not a
[ __ ] yeah but like
that's not they're not using it to buy
rent or manchester still like a normal
person going to the hospital and stuff
like i can't go to the doctor because i
can't afford it
but that's like saying a cancer patient
is like living a life of luxury because
they get all these expensive medicines
yeah using that to get to baseline they
need that much help
well do you think that they deserve to
stick around
yes i think they deserve to suck away
from this evil system in this evil
country
we deserve to take care of them we
deserve less money than we have paid
taxes sales tax i was paying 45 percent
it was a sailboat
yeah i paid taxes on the sale
sale individuals it's a sales tax also
there is a sale tax
there's a seal tax but uh what do you
think do you think this is fine like
just we just have homeless that we
create we just have to
clean them up every now and then no give
them wet wipes
no like i uh i can't tell you how many
times i've been starving and thirsty and
i'm just like
i would kill for a wet wife right now
just wipe this hunger off my face
dude food is easy to get no i know it is
like i was like talking to this homeless
guy and he's asking me for money
but he was also saying how much how well
he eats he was like dude i had pizza
chicken wings hey good man hey good i'm
like and he's like can i get some money
and i'm like dude i can like your eyes
are so red like
i'm not gonna give you money if you're
high i'm sorry like i like drugs too but
like
like taking a break like being taking a
celebratory break
is for somebody who's worked hard all
day like that's my opinion
like if i've worked hard i have
something to celebrate
then i can take a break but if you're
taking charity from other people because
you're not
able to do anything yeah then maybe you
don't deserve a break yet maybe you need
to work hard to earn a break
i think so there's no avenue for them to
work hard they can work hard all day
how is there an avenue for me to work
hard because you have a bank account
yeah it's also like security it's also
like
i don't work at all and like if a
homeless person stands outside
for 10 hours a day asking for money he's
working harder than i am
and if he wants to get high at the end
of the day that's that's fine he
deserves that as much as i do
i just get high all day without even
working he's not
but i'm lucky enough that i'm not how do
you get the money to get the drugs
you go to work uh i mean yeah but a
little bit but like i'm not like i have
family that supports me like i i don't
okay i know that's what i'm saying it's
just like i don't
i don't deserve more just because i'm in
a better place and i
can afford to get high you know that
doesn't make me like
more than you you know it's just like
everyone does deserve breaks and does
deserve like
good life yeah i mean if so it's just
like if you're saying you should be
working hard
why aren't you telling that to me
because you're not asking me for
something
but um yeah i think that just because
you're high doesn't mean that you don't
deserve help
i think that if you're on the streets
that you should get high
because life is depressing and your
brain is a very fragile
organ that needs the correct chemicals
and you got to inject
happiness chemicals into it or else
you're going to have a shitty brain it's
going to cause despair
yeah i guess i just feel we have a
different philosophy of what life
is like my idea is remember i was going
to get a six flags tattoo a long time
ago
my idea is that life is like kind of a
video game it's like we're playing call
of duty
and i work hard at it and i enjoy it i
like it and it's like some people are
literally playing call of duty
being like this [ __ ] sucks man
like the whole time like exit the game
but whatever literally what if the game
sucks what if the game is unfair
call of duty yeah what if people are
hacking the game what if they
up the unfairness so that they can yeah
jeff bezos joins and then nukes everyone
and you're like this is not fun anymore
yeah you have a choice to keep playing
or to exit but don't come constantly
come up to me
with like huge problems that you
it's not going to ever get better why
what do you do this is this society has
never existed in the world this
way it is is just it's a simulation
that's going badly according to you
right it's a simulation that's going
badly but like i'm still enjoying it
as long as uh people aren't touching me
with their disease i'm sick
after after the i don't was at a
homeless shelter
yesterday i got a cold but just because
you're happy doesn't mean that we
shouldn't change
the society we're in if it's hurting
others
i think that like i think i could
survive
anywhere but that you can't
like there's refugees there's syrian
civil war there's places that you would
not
like i worked on them for a year and a
half yeah but you wouldn't survive there
if you landed in syria
while you were getting bombed you'd be
as and that's why my thing is like the
philosophy is
the it's i believe in reincarnation
so i'm kind of like yeah i would get
bombed and then i would start over
hopefully in a better place like but
that's not a solution you can't just be
like just wait to get right i'll just
start over
yeah i'll just wait till i die like but
i wouldn't give up
i would keep playing the game in syria
until i got bombed
start over but how many people do we
have to just be like okay this is fine
uh i'll make the best of it life is fun
or we can like change it to make it life
actually fun for everyone
so but like that's the thing though
because when you talk to me and riley
about it
i don't know what riley's doing but i'm
doing a lot to help the world
or whatever like i'm doing everything i
can and
uh maybe maybe riley needs to do more i
don't know
wow [ __ ] you but you can do it you were
just saying it doesn't matter you can
just respawn
well i'm just saying like in my life
like i'm doing things
to help like okay good for you working
really hard
i would i'll vote with you and [ __ ] like
that but like
to keep uh to keep blaming me
like i'm just an uber don't blame me i'm
just arguing i'm just doing what you're
saying
things are fine you just have to do a
little bit here i'm happy i choose to be
happy
and not to like be part of the
complainers i
um even though i complain about it
you're complaining i'm complaining
you're complaining about the complainers
yeah but i mean happiness is like easy
like after i get that
what like if the people around me are
suffering i don't give a [ __ ] if i'm
happy like happiness is not the goal
yeah i don't want to just be happy what
is the goal uh
everyone people who are happy feel
shitty when when they're not even really
part of the problem part of the problem
well you're arguing saying that like
things are fine we just need people to
work harder
like and that's what i'm why i'm arguing
with you but if you're like actually
doing things that's great
thanks i am but i mean it's just like
what are you actually out of applause
for christy the uber driver
what do you think that uh
what do you think about like you know
like what do you think we could change
and why would you stand in the way of
people who actually have solutions to
the things that are wrong
but i'm not standing in the way am i
you're arguing with me
being like you're a communist dude you
don't have like don't your only
solutions
is to like certain policies i feel like
aren't aren't good because we're paying
a lot already like i said i was paying
45 percent
in new york and a lot of it is going to
corrupt officials i was in the
government
and the official but you're not saying
anything about de-corrupting the
officials you're just saying you put
more money more money and it's all
i'm high percentages are going to their
kids
those people's kids yeah we need to get
rid of corruption we need to like have a
political system
and but you never actually say that
you're just like more money for
everybody
and it's like it's not for everybody
it's for remember
when they pulled up on joe rogan like
how many millions
are going to the homelessness thing in
la but what it is is
people pocketing it at the top of the
world yeah i want to fix that too
like the corporate elite like the
billionaire class like that's where all
the evil is coming from
charities if you google like uh if you
google um
there's like a charity watch but the
only reason that is allowed to continue
is because people
like you guys are like it's fine if
things are unfair like just play the
game
yeah and if we change that attitude we
can fix the corruption
yeah i'm all for fixing the corruption
but you have to fire a lot of people you
have to
you have to like eliminate a lot of
charities
we have to think differently as a
generation and be like we can't just
have a mad dash for the
prize and leave people behind we need to
we need to think about others and go
forward as a group the slowpokes
the turtles like the american heart
association the ceo takes home five
million a year
of the donations you know and that's not
that's like although that's someone like
you who's like like six flags
yeah you would you're doing it right now
you're like oh that's fine
it's just about my pleasure very [ __ ]
hard and i cared about like
that this is the taxpayer's money i
worked very hard
but you're like things can't change just
my own happiness is
what's most important that i say that
now is because of my experience
in those places because i saw the
corruption so you're just going to let
it continue
well it seems to be so many people it
seems to be everyone and they don't care
it's because we have a culture of it we
can just respond
yeah you can you can definitely like get
a big platform and then call them out
but like which is i actually agreed with
trump about the u.n stuff he was like
it's a
bunch of corrupt people and i was like
that's true
but um i worked really hard and i would
like for instance i would produce 12
units a day for instance
and all the other people would produce
like one
and i would say like they're not working
unit
of what i don't want to like it's i'm
just trying to talk fast
this is like 12 chapters a day of this
thing and they would produce one chapter
yeah and uh i would say like i would
compare my i would say like look this is
pretty easy for me to like
do these 12 chapters i don't know what
they're doing how you produce one a day
and then my boss the chief editor said
don't stop comparing yourself and he got
we were in a fight the whole time he
actually like didn't let me get a
promotion at another job because he said
he didn't like me
he said that i compared myself to other
people and i was like that's capitalism
that's what it is is that all these
communist corrupt people
produce one chapter a day and they get
drunk at lunch
i don't think that's what it is i think
this is taxpayer i think the u.n is like
a beautiful idea on top of an evil
system and that corrupts
the same system that's responsible for
america and the u.n
because america controls the u.n they do
so i mean you try to have a nice rose on
top of a pile of [ __ ]
the roses kind of turn to [ __ ] too well
the the charter controls you and in the
charter says that no one can be fired
once they're hired at the u.n
unless they do something violently like
a huge crime
and that's why like the the president of
the u.n always gets ousted as
having 49 rolexes and like just so many
millions like
hidden that he's like been stealing yeah
but why wouldn't they they're
in a society where everyone is doing
that everyone's trying to be a
chamillionaire
or a rapper yeah a soundcloud person so
they're coming from that world it's true
like i would definitely rail against
that culture but like i don't have a big
enough platform to really like
to to actually help change that culture
but it's all of those people in there
and uh so uh what do you think about the
austin comedy scene
i was gonna say something else what were
you gonna say
uh i guess that was it i don't i don't
know
it's just that like uh the culture of
corruption
and evil yeah they don't need any
basically just that like they don't need
any more money because
it's about where they're putting the
money
yeah but it's not about
money it's about having a charitable
heart and actually trying to solve
problems instead of just trying to get
your own [ __ ]
so i mean what do you think about austin
comedy
uh i might go to new york for this like
for some of the summer
just to like mix it up yeah what about
you
i like it uh i think there's not as many
amazing comedians as in new york really
yeah i think uh austin comedy there's a
lot of people who've been doing it two
two three years oh like not a lot of
people above
that how long i think you've been doing
it for longer
two years
yeah um but
that's okay yeah you've been working
hard
making 12 units while everyone else is
making only one
units 12 whole units so
like in new york who is a good like
mark norman is that what you're talking
about
yeah or like usama siddiqui
yeah or i guess he doesn't have aids yet
and died what he looks like he has hates
yeah
uh he like has a lot of sex i don't know
he talks he talks to me like i think he
has
something about women a lot of you guys
do but like what do you think about
women i mean attraction
huh you mean attraction to me he just
talks to me like he he thinks he knows
what i'm going to say
and it's not what i was going to say and
then he's already gone by the time
he did that just quickly and then do
you think you know what i'm gonna say
but you don't know what i'm saying
i don't know you guys are just like
talking about
uh actual stuff yeah you don't know
what would you want to talk about
yourself which is funny
it's just random stuff like like the
supernatural creature in india
sure okay or what about beau burnham
your
idol um yeah i think he's really
talented and i'm jealous of his talents
but you don't sing do you no you didn't
sing ever at the karaoke thing
i did i mean i didn't really know the
song oh i wonder if it's filming my foot
kicking yeah yeah we're selling this uh
to
defeat fetish websites
but uh yeah i mean sorry we're not
producing good cause no i mean
i i mean i i mean i'm over here thinking
like i'm the bad person for like not
caring about like
policies and stuff um but i just
really just don't care at all i let you
guys
i said y'all are leading it and then
immediately y'all had an argument about
how he cares about capitalism right yeah
yeah well
and then we argue again about it yeah
well you i mean you guys just know more
than i do so
i i feel like what we got to is that we
agree that
we agree that like where our two bubbles
like connect
is corruption yeah
so we got we found an agreement the
world is corrupt full of corruption
yeah and like his is like we should give
money to everyone and mine
is like stop and [ __ ] have a charitable
heart
yeah and you agree with just like i
agree we just need to be chill
yeah yeah let's all have good vibes
i mean i just want everyone to love each
other
and love me for who i am even the sick
and the poor
yeah and i think that
yeah yeah i remember jesus said
it's easy to love the beautiful and the
smart
but it's the sick and the poor and the
like kind of evil that it's hard to love
and those are the people that like but
like those are the ones that's most
important to love them
if you want to be jesus i do yeah
i mean not really i mean i'll be a
i'll be like kind of jesus i'll be like
a jesus where you
you kind of don't know if he's going to
help you or not
hey jesus like i need help i know you're
helping all those others like yeah i
don't know i gotta
challenge you jesus he's like
i don't know i think i'm just gonna go
smoke weed hey could you give me a ride
yeah this
this leprosy victim is really harsh in
my mellow man
yeah let's go to sleep is leprosy like
even that bad of a thing like isn't that
just the skin condition
it's like you don't feel [ __ ] in your
fingers so you put your hand on a hot
stove and it burns off and you don't
realize it
um that doesn't sound that bad
it's really important to feel your face
well that's what leprosy is you can't
feel anything
i thought it was the skin like you had
skin clots skin [ __ ] too
it's really destroyed it's been
destroyed by now it's not a thing
anymore
but uh you know like sex dolls their
fingers are always getting destroyed
because they're like the most delicate
parts so they're like
you know that there's like well people
are like holding hands
yeah cause like they're so small and
like you can get them
clipped and stuff yeah that must suck
as a guy who's dating a sex doll when
you're when
your other person just starts
deteriorating and like
i mean you can like fix it but like it's
like
it's not like the same yeah or when
you're dating a human
woman and she starts deteriorating yeah
they do they do that i know but they
don't
do that like at the same rate
they do it oh man like most of them do
dude
no it takes them like a 90 years to
deteriorate but it's not like they're
it's not like their bone structure
breaking and like they're yeah true i
guess if you're a sex doll
it'd be like you could date like a 25
year old forever
you have to like most 22 year old girls
are
[ __ ] by the time they're 25. so you
have to
if what do you mean you're really shout
botox
uh you gotta save money you have to have
that you have to get a 20 year old
or 18 however far you want to go down
there 18
and then get rid of her before she hits
25.
and then you got to flip you got to flip
five years at a time with these girls
who are you tom's first and then some
girls like me
remain healthy i mean
i think a lot of girls are really
healthy
can you name any that are not currently
below
25. helen mirren angelina jolie
jennifer aniston one angelina jolie is
actually
aging very questionably according to her
fans and she's actually very young she's
like 34.
really no way yeah she's 32 very
questionably
yes okay well what about uh natalie
portman
again these people are rare stars and
that's why they're able to
but i'm talking about like every 22 year
old you see on the street you're like
damn she's so
fine and it's like turned into a puerto
rican
on the streets that's what i'm trying to
say she has three years no i feel like
really hot like
30 year olds all the time dude he goes
he he he shoves me like evidence and
it's
jennifer lopez the one person jennifer
lopez
the one i have a bit about her like that
she's like an astronaut for women we're
like go further further further
she's i love her no this is announcing
angelina jolie angelina
oh sorry she's 10 years older
you know dude it's just like american
culture that looks up to
younger people that's true yeah asians
don't do that
yeah we respect our elders
um i think yeah it's kind of gross to be
like to
like like for especially like moms who
like can't really
like they're like they're used to being
like the hot girl
and now they're not and it's just like
why do we put them in the
in that position that in the first place
just like no i don't i don't think like
i i think that's just a huge problem why
do you put them in what position in the
first like you have like
you have to be hot you have to be the
standard of beauty
and it's just and if you're not hot that
means you're less like because we
we like i mean yeah like girls just only
get treated
for being hot and like and then they get
used to that and then like they're like
oh wait if i'm not hot anymore what am i
because
they have like a huge identity crisis we
have no use for humans behind
besides sex like if we treated people
well and honor them for their scientific
discoveries
saying that we would have any use for a
human
like why because that's
the only reason to exist is to create a
beautiful world
like that we can all live like don't you
want to live in the garden of eden
my garden if you even what eden would be
a private club with only a
very exclusive yeah but you would be in
that club you wouldn't have
people trying to kill each other and
like oh you didn't perform you'd never
die
kicked out before they got to that so
you want to live in a garden of eden
where you can get kicked out of it
yes why that's not a garden of eden yes
it is and that's why
it's no it's not if somebody's being
uncool they get they're out
that's not a garden of eden you gotta
stop them from being uncool
under i-35 then my garden of eden would
be a world where we don't have to have
people
working to survive yeah that's some
barbaric primitive [ __ ]
i mean you know it's it's hard out there
like you know
it's artificially hard like we make it
hard for no reason
i don't know because like they've never
been able to make one
and it's because it's like even
even when nothing was artificial they've
never been able to make like
yeah they have hunter gatherers are much
happier than we are
they are but they also war with each
other and like
are you sure yeah because they're
nomadic they just move
i don't know i i don't like the aztecs
and the incas and the mayans like the
way that they like
uh wanted to commit suicide so badly
they would say they weren't really
hunter-gatherers
they were like civilizations but i mean
like
don't like what is the point of this
earth if it's not to like create an
awesome
world like why are we creating this yeah
crazy world where people are just like
cut off if they don't perform
well and that's where our philosophies
change again because
it's kind of like uh a little bit of
more minimalism over here
of like an awesome world is where i
choose who the cool people are
and it's like i think that you three are
cool in austin
thank you for letting us live i'm not
allowing noey to be
here for no this is the garden of eden
eden right now you said
you don't have to hang with people you
don't like but you also can't kill them
and destroy their existence from the
earth
well he'll do that to himself once he
commits another crime and inputs
and goes to jail forever and then you'll
give him a wet wipe
[Laughter]
you can wipe away the tears it's a whole
container of wet wipes
way one single wet wipe they'd be like
yeah it's dry
you like give people wet lights like
this one single one
yeah yeah like can you um
me and hans can't have a funny podcast
because like we'll just
i know politically we'll debate well man
that's what some people like
i know but like uh people like boring
podcasts that would be crazy
you know that'd be crazy i mean you guys
should have just done it without me
do you guys laugh when you do yours
together yeah
all the time we talk about donkey
[ __ ]
uh-huh tijuana no like
colombia like they have cultures where
the young men
[ __ ] donkeys to get used to sex
we can't just do the same content as the
last episode no one
listens to this that's what i was asking
somebody else and like
they were like no way and i was like i
don't know i feel like
how many single men out in the middle of
nowhere
are having sex with their female dogs
yeah a lot of times
i mean i don't what do you mean they
know that about each other like the
donkey [ __ ] like
uh they don't that's a huge bunch of
sheep and everything it's like
do other men come over to this guy's
farm and know [ __ ] that
yeah why is that sheep following you
yeah because dude like in in uh
[ __ ] colombia like yeah that's like
the thing it's just like
oh dude like which donkey did you [ __ ]
last night like i [ __ ] that one
i [ __ ] the [ __ ] the brown one with the
long hair oh she's pretty odd like i
[ __ ] this
other like blonde donkey and like and
there was
and there's guys that like cheat on
their wives with donkeys that's gross
and they're like they're like they're
like thinking about donkeys while
they're [ __ ] their wife like
are you sure like yes yes like look it
up it's like a vice thing
oh okay um and there's a bunch of other
articles on it and
women don't [ __ ] man um
no i i mean yeah i don't know why that's
dancing boys in iraq
dancing bush um it's not even about
like they're doing it up to themselves
they're making it illegal for a woman to
come outside and party
so they [ __ ] little boys so they bring
out little boys to party
and they kind of dress like women let's
get the adult
females out of here and bring the child
yeah
boys that's so that's at least
that i mean it sounds like they just
want to do that
i mean i can't think of any other reason
women are unclear yeah
it's the manliest thing to [ __ ] another
man
it is true it's very manly i mean greeks
did it you know they would wrestle and
then
yeah so i don't know what how you all
feel when you say those types of things
well i think a lot of those things would
be how do you feel women would just
if i was a man and i said that around my
boys
your boys i would understand that they
knew that i was going to try to [ __ ]
them
eventually what but don't it's like a
power i'd be like yeah i mean it's the
most powerful
manly thing to to dominate all of your
i mean not everything i say is an
implied threat
yeah you just have to take it that way
because you're a woman and
you have to be on guard constantly okay
i'm gonna
hey something's gonna happen tonight and
if it does so
what
dude i mean man [ __ ] that's the
hottest thing and
i don't know i think straight guys like
to joke around about homosexuality
because
we can't really do it so like that's our
way of like
doing it to each other yeah that's it's
like it's like oh we don't joke around
yeah okay making eye contact wait
but are you bisexual no have you met
any men who you knew that they
had sex with their dogs i think this is
this is a thing that you just made up no
one does that in america
it's not culturally i mean i'm sure
somebody do it
you're like
a female dog is so happy and loves you
so much oh
and cuddling with you yeah but it's
furry and breath is
hot okay so female i've never seen a
dog vagina does it like come out like a
is it like it comes out it comes out
like a
dude you'd probably destroy it we got
big comes out if it's used
so it's just it's a it's it's not
reusable it's just uh it comes out
it's like a paper plate it just pops up
collapses once it's like uh
it's like an air bag it's like
like the nipples also like are out
after yeah suck on some nipples
yeah i love sucking on twelve nipples
i always like whatever i got elevator
buttons and i would always like
when i would rub their bellies for a
long time i would play with their
nipples
um
um yeah i mean that is like it's kind of
it's kind of weird when i'm like
when i'm petting my dog i'm rubbing his
belly
nipples it's just a sensitive area it's
pleasure sorry well it does get covered
derek's nipples are hard apparently yeah
but like when when i like i'm like
rubbing my dog's belly it's like
sometimes like accidentally like touches
penis i'm like ah you have to go around
the penis for five minutes yeah
actually finish them to completion
on accident yeah that was so
embarrassing
the worst thing that ever happened to me
is i had a male kitten
and i was like he was like laying above
my head and i was like
petting massaging him or whatever and
like after a very long time
i realized that it was his testicles oh
because i was like it's like this
squishy like furry thing that i'm like
massaging
no way yeah it's so funny what did you
think it was
i just like maybe his thigh or something
and i just like
like as time went on i was like what
i thought that you were just laying down
you were just like reading a book
just yeah she's so cat
uh that is so funny it's so perverted
and wrong
you know in some cultures they take a
baby and then they
put their genitals in their mouth
because yeah
no not like a circumcision what they
like play with their genitals because
it's like
the baby likes it dude the baby's like
exactly
no got your penis
it's just uh you're not on mike you're
not on mike
uh he said in india that's a common way
for a mother to sue the child
that's sexual assault but that's such an
american
type of cultural baby viewpoint
the baby ejaculates no he doesn't he
doesn't go
through puberty we'll do your podcast
yeah they're going to prop b you after
this
um does the baby have like a
probably an orgasm though no dude you
just have a pleasurable experience
i think me i think females can i don't
think guys
not until your balls drop this whole
idea that
any time someone touches your genitals
yes insult
is like something yeah that is like i
understand that that's like
comes from repression and shame yeah
like i can't get rid of my parents
made it a very shameful thing for me and
i tell them every single day
like [ __ ] life
and um so when you're asexual
yeah what do your parents shame you in
it's a shameful thing like they hate did
you rub yourself on the couch
didn't want to talk to me anymore like
they just wanted a kid
you're too hot yeah and yeah you don't
really think about like that
they didn't think that i was ever going
to become a sexual being and they hated
it when i
when it looked like i might should have
had your spanish and
uh also
in the south everyone's kind of like
that too and then
it's an american thing so it's like
piled up so
if you had a baby would you put its
genitals in your mouth if it's crying
it's like oh it's so
so noisy it won't shut out the only
thing let me suck his dick
yeah that's a crime that is not a crime
you can get the balls in the dick and
like like it's like a clamp
you know when you're eating a like why
did you do an accent
no slurp his balls the baby's crying he
wants
are you a good mother or not
be a good mother and suck your baby's
dick
comedians are too much sometimes dude
you're a [ __ ] comedian first it's
like
this isn't funny now it's like it's too
comedic dude one time i
did 10 heads of lsd and i was hanging
out with this comedian for the rest of
the for the whole day
the next day and there were so many
moments where i was like i think
comedians are too harsh
because i was like tripping and he would
say these like jokes that were so
like well maybe it was just that one guy
it could have been like
he was talking to an indian he was like
are you a are you a red dot indian or a
yeah and i was just like oh is this
actually
like i was like thinking about like when
is comedy like a nice
it was like i was tripping so hard i was
like this is like never
nice it's always like these like harsh
jabs
at things yeah well do you think putting
babies
balls in your mouth is harsh or very
versatile
i think that's a crime and when you did
it and you did it in an
asian accent you said oh you stop you
why you stop crying you need to stop
crying no that's offensive
yeah dude hunch can you just speak in an
english accent from now on
like what are you making fun of my asian
accent that actually could be how you
were talking just
naturally yeah oh baby so cute oh little
bit little peanuts
why you crying so much give me your
penis oh
put in my mouth i love so much
but
to do research though i will what about
like i'll tell you something
spanking a baby on the butt like
playfully like on the diaper
i mean i guess like if it's crawling
around and laughing
in certain scenarios you would sexually
assault a baby
i think you could kind of like he's
asking for it being like a wedding
it was something throw something at it
that's even worse than putting it in
your mouth dude imagine
it's kind of like a thing i think my dog
dogs are like really like turned on by
that i feel like my dog gets like turned
on sometimes
like when i'm petting it i know like
with my tongue just like
[Music]
you call me like that's the natural
thing because if they didn't enjoy it
no it's just audio now if it was it's
not recording
no the battery died you want me to put
it if it didn't enjoy it
let's wrap it up let's wrap it up let's
wrap it up all right well this is hans
kim
what do you have to say last final words
that's it
thank you that's it yeah which part of
this are you gonna clip to clip
i'll look through it and fast-forward
motion
are you going to crop us out yeah
no you're going to exile us
to create a perfect wall that's funny
no i wouldn't crop you out it's okay i
wouldn't mind thanks
i might crop you out during some of it
where you weren't talking
yeah that's fine yeah but i don't know i
don't care
well um thanks for having us on your
podcast
thanks for having me and christy on your
podcast
dude he said at the beginning we didn't
prepare anything
what do you want to talk about so so
that was you that did that we kind of
planned baby i mean
uh i'm fine with just going with the
flow as long as the flow doesn't involve
politics whoa
what why do you hang out with hansen
yeah i don't
i mean i i don't like he hates that
about that [ __ ]
but it's okay you know everybody has
their thing and
you know you look like aoc so uh
you look like ratchet aoc you look like
tulsi gabbard she was hotter
how am i rushing aot because you're like
yeah i look like aoc and she was on mali
for three days
yeah if she went to lollapalooza yeah
do you guys want to play frisbee outside
it's beautiful uh yeah yes
conclusion okay thank you all right see
ya